[Music]
when I hear people bring up grammar in
daily conversations most of the time
it's interchangeable with proper grammar
ain't ain't a word double negations are
ungrammatical always use who as a
subject but whom as an object following
these kinds of rules makes your speech
sound polite educated and prestigious
this proper grammar is telling you how
to use your language linguists call it
prescriptive grammar because it
prescribes certain words and structures
if prescription demands that you follow
certain grammar rules it's a linguistic
do this prescription prohibits you from
breaking rules
it's a linguistic don't do that but now
you've come over to the native language
here and these videos talk about grammar
differently you learn that in Catalan a
language native to eastern Spain they
put articles before proper nouns I'll
feed the large wanna literally means the
son of the Joanne but that's how they
say the son of Joanne or Joanne's son
maybe you even find out that in earlier
English double negatives were common and
expected like in non Edelsten anthing
ask em yup that is English and it
literally means no one dared not ask
nothing these are real-life descriptions
of language this is descriptive grammar
notice the difference one approach
attempts to dictate how speakers ought
to speak their language the other one
captures and documents language
objectively as it is being used not as
some people wish it were used
historical descriptions show us that
prescriptive rules go into an out of
fashion double negatives were once
mainstream in English but now they're
marginalized cultural differences show
us that prescriptive rules don't apply
to all languages so they're not
fundamental to human language or grammar
yes from this perspective the
prescriptive rules you hear from grammar
geeks and style guides sound flighty and
incidental but before we shout nobody
tells me what to do and race to dump
prescriptivism in the trash let's think
about the possible upside establishing a
standard language could boost social
cohesion monumental works of literature
standardize reference resources like
dictionaries and the education of a
highly literate population traditionally
involved and maybe even depend on some
amount of prescriptivism prescriptivism
and descriptivism both talk about
language use but both of them stop short
of offering a model of human language a
model explains human language it's a
theory of language for example
chomps in theories of generative grammar
see language as a group of rules that
once activated in the right way will
produce the structure of the specific
language on the other hand functional
theories of grammar see language as a
linguistic instrument for communicating
in social situations
prescriptive descriptive theoretical
you'll sound smart when you get the
chance to work these concepts into at
least one upcoming conversation
what's more now you can see some of the
reasons behind dividing the study of
language into different fields I hope
you've enjoyed this topic as much as I
have please subscribe for more on
linguistics languages and logic in the
future and thank you for learning with
me